so for example
so this is this is where i want to kind
of get into some of the issues
so if war is taking place in other
places and the country is getting
stronger by strong arming other people
and picking up countries left and right
we should stay out of it
yes
if it doesn't threaten our country then
yeah but let's just say russia well
let's just stay out of it russia picks
up ukraine guys don't do anything china
picks up hong kong guys just don't do
anything you know chance like listen
we're big enough screw it australia
seems weak why don't we put a 10-year
plan to go take over australia no guys
just don't do anything
does that also mean as other
uh power empires keep getting stronger
and stronger and stronger we just sit on
the sidelines and do nothing well
once they get to canada i'd start
getting the best way to deal with the
china threat is to look at why china's a
threat china at one point was a country
that was starving to death by the tens
of millions we have to look at why that
actually happened why they've gone from
that to being arguably the second large
second or possibly most powerful country
on earth and it's because of the fact
that cronies in the u.s and other
western countries realized that the best
way they could protect their market
share of their various industries that
they were in was to create such a high
regulatory and tax burden in the u.s and
in north america and in other western
countries that they would basically shut
out all the rest of their competition
create such a high barrier to entry that
more disruptive smaller competitors
could not compete they did that knowing
that eventually they would they would uh
poison the water so much domestically
that even they couldn't produce here but
they were fine with that because they
were already working to develop uh good
cozy relationships with dictatorial
regimes overseas like china and then use
the us military to protect their goods
and services that they're making over
there all the way back here to sell back
to the american people that is the
problem the root problem of china is
that the the us and the west
the regulatory and tax structure in this
country i mean you you run businesses i
ran businesses it's so high that there
are people that are moving all their
jobs over there if we made it more
fertile ground for people to do business
here people are going to want to do
business here instead of a country
that's telling their company you can't
even criticize us or we won't let you
work here we won't let you operate here
i i think that's right and i i also
think that um look that we have to be
somewhat realistic i think that the the
america the hubris of the uh american
national federal government and its
spokespeople is so out of control that
people have this like empire mentality
so the question becomes can we let china
take taiwan should we let them do that
you know now i don't want the chinese
communist party to rule taiwan i would
rather taiwan be more free than less
free i want everyone to be free the
truth is that we cannot stop them from
doing that and the idea that we somehow
it would you want to go to an h-bomb war
and destroy half of the world and then
they still take taiwan after that we we
do not have an option to have a direct
military confrontation with russia or
china humanity cannot survive that in
the broader picture if you're talking
about countries dominating other
countries i don't think there's too many
examples where a poorer country goes and
takes over a richer country that doesn't
tend to happen it's a richer more
powerful country that takes over a poor
country okay the best defense against
that is happening us and our allies be
as rich
the answer to that is free market
capitalism that's how you produce wealth
so you want to keep your economy as free
market as possible so that you are as
wealthy as possible and therefore not
vulnerable to being taken over i got a
follow-up for you but you want to say
something by the way i said i said hong
kong earlier it's taiwan correction
thank you for doing that go ahead what
you talk about the policy and balancing
the publishing that also i don't talk
about that's uh milton friedman talked
about it you were bringing that up yes
the problem you have with that is when
you say those words the average american
gets really afraid because what the
government is everyone else always said
here is a monopoly
so there are many communities now and
the lockdowns taught us this they have
lost the institutional knowledge to
support themselves because they've been
supported by government for so long they
literally cannot support themselves so
if you just knock down that government
monopoly they will have nothing and they
are afraid of that also for many of
these communities they're in a bad spot
they are kept down by government and
employed by government so now when you
take government away they are no longer
kept down but they're also no longer
employed
so we can't just we can but we shouldn't
just abolish government what we should
do is support the community in
supporting itself right there are
policies you can do to begin that one of
the policies i had is if you are a new
york state resident and you're going to
you know pay your taxes at the end of
the year you can take up the 250 of that
you would spend send to the state and
instead send to any non-profit and if
it's a local nonprofit supporting
localism it's 500 bucks you might go 500
bucks how much is that what if it's a
thousand thousand people doing it 10 000
people doing it you can begin to support
non-profits locally community not
government-sponsored non-profits
government-sponsored non-profits are
simply government agencies that are not
unionized but actual local communities
that will assist and get the communities
up and running people do need help i
just believe in my heart i think
everyone here does communities and
families are going to be better at
supporting people than some government
agency if we support that first then
government will either go away or
somehow get better and if we can get
better but it'll just begin to go away
because community will support community
and that's the piece we have to begin to
support communities first so okay can
capitalism stand on its own without uh
law and order
oh no well i mean you need laws in the
world
but i mean look what you need but just
to be more specifically uh to be more
specific what when we're talking about
law and order let's be clear about what
we're talking about what you need is the
protection of people and property yeah
like that's very specifically what you
need that people and their property need
to be protected against aggressors now
whoever you think should do that that
service certainly has to be done the
problem that we have today under state
policing is that at for
they're always either doing more than
that or less than that right so you
always you have things where you have uh
uh gun control and the war on drugs and
these kind of militarization of the
police and tens of thousands of swat
raids a year where it to the point where
like you know my uh my friend uh tim
poole who you know on on the tim cass
show he's been swatted like multiple
times because it's that easy to just
swat someone yeah you can literally just
call them and go oh here there's they're
holding people or they're killing people
here and they go and it's by the fourth
time it's happened the the the police
department isn't going yeah we probably
don't believe you because you've already
done this three times
so you're we have this one thing where
we're they're going well beyond
protecting people and property and they
become an authoritarian force and then
we have other examples in a lot of these
blue cities right now where they're
doing less than that not protecting
property not protecting you know not you
can shoplift up to a thousand dollars in
san francisco or whatever exact the rule
is and that leads to chaos so what you
want to find is you want to get as close
as possible to the perfect equilibrium
of protecting people and property no
more and no less
so i personally i think private security
it does a better job of that than state
police do so i'd want to see that
expanded as much so that's the concept
right why do we have things like why is
possession
of a drug a crime
right that's the type of thing we're
talking about why is some activity that
doesn't hurt anybody why is that a crime
are these a victimless crimes is selling
get a crime why would it be a crime
selling cocaine or crime it is a crime
it should not be
it is a crime it shouldn't be correct
because it's my choice whether i want to
buy it or not i can go to the fda yeah
and i can get a drug that will get me
hooked in opioids should anything be
illegal to sell
when i asked joe this question should
anything be illegal to sell yes there
are issues that you don't want to sell
certain things to certain ages of course
you have age restrictions on things to
sell 100 should i be able to sell the
super emps should i be able to sell
nuclear to help you have nuclear power
should i if you got the money you got
all the billions maybe i want to sell it
to you as an individual well should i be
able to sell that if there's someone who
can afford to buy a nuclear power
there's a lot of guys today that can't
yes if they can buy the power plant and
they want nuclear power plant they're
going to get a nuclear power plant if
they actually want it they're going to
go get it it doesn't matter and no one
has so this is a question that
libertarians get asked a lot because
we're we're against the war on drugs and
the war on guns and so people will go to
the extreme and say well what about
nukes it's important to note that no
person outside of a state or government
has nukes right now not because they
can't get them but because who else but
a government would want to have nukes in
fact the entire nuclear energy system we
have right now which was originally
built more towards the production of
nuclear weapons than actual nuclear
energy which is why it's not as
efficient as things like thorium plants
and things like that is because it was
government leading the way on it saying
well no our top priority is having
nuclear bombs before they realize that
it would destroy the planet and that
they couldn't use them as freely as they
were using them like in hiroshima and
nagasaki that was going to be a new
arsenal that they would use all the time
but the point of that is
absent the need by a central authority
by a centrally planned authority to rule
over others there's not really a good
reason to have a nuke it's not something
you're able to be able to use uh in good
reason you have a lot of things though
there's i'm just asking like yeah
i'm asking a question because i'm asking
the question to challenge the philosophy
if there's a limit to the philosophy i'm
not asking it because tomorrow i want to
buy a nuclear weapon so let me let me go
to a different area let me touch this
piece this is common well then we'll
we'll all die we'll all explode the
world will end let's start having those
conversations let's start having
conversations on what type of machine
gun we can have or whatever let's have
that conversation not whether i can
defend myself in my home we are so far
from what you're talking about it's it's
on the planet right on this so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]